to mark the release of Hotel
Transylvania 2 let's take a look at 12
things you probably didn't know about
the animated monster movie director
genndy tartakovsky was pretty nervous
about directing comedy legend Mel Brooks
who voices Dracula's father Vlad because
he grew up loving the comedian's movies
indeed in the late 1970s some of the
first movies Tartakovsky saw as a child
after he moved from Russia to America
when Mel Brooks's films such as Young
Frankenstein and Blazing Saddles and
Brooks his movies certainly came in
handy when they were making Hotel
Transylvania 2 as the filmmakers used
them as reference material for drawing
Vlad's reactions and expressions as for
Mel Brooks well he drew much of his
inspiration in bringing Vlad to life on
screen from his own grandfather for the
design of the monster camp camp vamp the
filmmakers took inspiration from two
very different places which together
gave them the right look for the kind of
dark and private outdoor place that
vampires might enjoy the first was
Yosemite National Park and it's huge
rock formations including El Capitan and
the second was a Norwegian town of
rookin which used to spend half the year
cut off from sunlight because of its
location in a valley until that is huge
mirrors were placed on the surrounding
mountain to reflect sunlight into the
town square
when the character designers first
created Mavis and Johnny's son Dennis
they drew him with a big mane of red
hair like his father but when they
turned the design into a computer
animation
they found Dennis's hair looked too big
for his head to hold in fact Dennis's
hair took up so much room that Mavis or
Johnny would have needed arms twice the
length in order to pick him up and on
top of that his massive curls kept the
light from reaching his face so the
animators gave Dennis a haircut
six-year-old Asha blink off used the
voice of Drax granson Dennis isn't the
only member of his family to appear in
Hotel Transylvania 2 Ash's older sister
Meera not only voiced one of the world
wolf puppies in the first movie but
she's also doing some additional voices
in the sequel including vampire kids
Asha was especially excited to land the
role of Dennis because whenever here is
Cystic as a part in a film it's a family
tradition to go out for a sushi dinner
also according to Ash's mum one of the
highlights per her son of working on
Hotel Transylvania 2 was actually riding
in a golf cart around the Sony Pictures
studio lots dracs daughter Mavis was
designed by French artist
Annette mana who's based in Paris the
filmmakers never actually met Anne s in
real life but thanks to her blog they
discovered her work when they were
searching for character designers for
the first Hotel Transylvania the Hotel
Transylvania movies are a bit of a
family affair for Adam Sandler who
voices Drac on the first movie his
real-life wife Jackie provided the voice
of his on-screen wife Martha and his
daughter Sonny and Sadie also lent their
voices to the film with Sadie voicing
young Mavis and one of the werewolf pups
Winnie and Sonny and Sadie have returned
for Hotel Transylvania 2 Sadie is back
as were wolf Winnie while this time
sunny is the voice of baby Dennis as
well as one of the vampire kids when
character designer Carter Goodrich was
looking for inspiration for the design
of Griffin the invisible man who's
voiced by actor David Spade he didn't
have to look any further than his own
nose as Griffin's glasses are actually
based on the ones Goodrich was himself
the her style of Frankenstein's wife
Eunice is based on a brillo pads and
unisys her isn't the only rough thing
about her according to Fran Drescher who
voices Eunice during her recording
sessions the filmmakers kept encouraging
her to make Eunice sang gruffer more
obnoxious and more annoying fast Alona
based designer Carlos from hell who
contributed to the look of many of the
movie's characters including Marie the
mummy hates designing on white paper so
instead he drew all his monster designs
on the inside of cereal boxes which he
prefers to blank paper because it has
more color and texture to it which
helped him get creative in fact growl
hell asks fellow artists at his studio
in Spain to bring in their old cereal
boxes for him to draw on
Andy Samberg who voices Dracula's
son-in-law Jonathan has said he based
the character on himself in high school
and on a lot of guys he noob in the Bay
Area in California Jonathan is the kind
of guy who loved seeing the world and
it's super positive when faced with
adversity when Sony was designing
characters for Hotel Transylvania they
had to be very careful about copyright
issues although characters such as
Dracula and Frankenstein monster are in
the public domain
Universal created specific designs for
those characters in their popular horror
movies of the 1930s onwards so Sony had
to avoid certain features associated
with universals classic monsters for
example Frankenstein could not have
green skin or bolts in his neck and
Dracula could not have a sharp widow's
peak or a cape with a red lining also
instead of calling Frankenstein's mate
the Bride of Frankenstein
they called her Eunice and on top of
that she could not have two white
lightening bolts in her hair so in Hotel
Transylvania she has just one streak
instead now let me know in the comments
below who's your favorite character in
the Hotel Transylvania movies and why
and what would you like to see in the
plan Hotel Transylvania TV series if you
enjoyed this video do please share it
hit the thumbs-up button and subscribe
for more things you didn't know as well
as movie reviews and interviews thanks
for watching yippee-ki-yay movie lovers